zuverlässig mit eisernem Willen und sogar
gegen alle Widrigkeiten wie zum Beispiel
dieses lästige Ding namens Vernunft das Problem
ist nicht das trifft ja Lindner nicht gut darin
wäre zuständig zu sein das Problem ist dass er
offenbar für andere Dinge zuständig ist als er
offiziell behauptet ich glaube zum Beispiel
dass Oliver Blume der Porsche Chef ein sehr
glücklicher Mann ist weil Christian Lindner
offenbar dafür zuständig ist dass Oliver Blume
der Porsche-Chef ein sehr glücklicher Mann ist
aber natürlich sagt Herr Lindner nicht dass er
dafür zuständig ist wenn man dieser Logik folgt
muss man sich über alle Dinge von denen er sagt
dass er nicht für Sie zuständig ist keine Sorgen
machen Christian macht das schon aber wenn er
sagt dass er zuständig ist dann weiß ich nicht
dann hat er immer so eine guckt mal wie hart und
entschlossen ich das Problem angehe wie ein
Hamster der sein Hamsterrad immer schön so
drapiert dass es aussieht als würde er in Richtung
Fortschritt Rennen obwohl sein Rädchen eigentlich
nur eins von vielen Zahnrädern ist die die Uhr an
seinem eigenen Handgelenk rückwärts laufen lassen
ich sollte das mit den Bildern sein lassen
ich weiß nun ist er jedenfalls für den Kampf
gegen Geldwäsche zuständig und da geht das
Problem hart und entschlossen an eine neue
Bundesbehörde gründet er ein finanzkriminalamt und
da kündigt das mit großen Worten an er sagt mit
leistungsfähigen und wirksamen Strukturen werden
wir dafür sorgen dass die ehrlichen Kaufleute vor
denen geschützt werden die sich nicht an Regeln
halten vor denen die sich nicht an Regeln halten
das klingt fast schon niedlich es erinnert mich
an Friedrich Merz der über die letzte Generation
gesagt hat das sind keine klimaaktivisten das
sind Kriminelle Straftäter ich bin unsicher ob
es auch nicht kriminelle Straftäter gibt
aber wahrscheinlich konnte Friedrich Merz
einfach nicht genug betonen wie kriminell die
AktivistInnen sind wohin gegen Christian nimmt
man sich offenbar nicht dazu durchringen kann
Wirtschaftskriminelle überhaupt mit Kriminalität
in Verbindung zu bringen das sind nur Leute die
sich nicht an Regeln halten die kleinen Rabauken
natürlich Unrecht immerhin Gründe der extra eine
neue Bundesbehörde was ein ganz wundervolles
Mittel ist wenn man Dinge erledigt haben will
in ein paar Jahren so eine Behörde aufzubauen
dauert ja eine Weile es ist ein bisschen wie
Kernfusion für Wirtschaftskriminalität kann
irgendwann funktionieren funktioniert jetzt
gerade aber vor allem als Ausrede um nicht
vom Sofa aufzustehen und ich finde es toll wir
werfen Politiker in noch immer vor sie würden
nie über ihre Amtszeit hinaus denken Christian
Lindner schon er denkt wenn ich es jetzt schaffe
noch zweieinhalb Jahre richtig beschäftigt
auszusehen muss erst wirklich etwas getan
werden wenn ich schon nicht mehr zuständig
bin ich frage mich ja immer wie konstruktiv
und effizient Christian Lindner wohl sein könnte
wenn er sich selbst erlauben würde seine Energie
in Sinnvolles zu stecken vielleicht ist
der Trick einfach dass wir ihn bei allen
wichtigen Dingen sagen nee sorry Christian
dafür bist Du leider nicht zuständig [Applaus]
vergessen was denn na das Abo die Glocke
was dann war das ja alles ganz umsonst
vielleicht wissen unsere Zuschauer
auch selbst wo sie abonnieren können
das jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr klug